[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the six most powerful members
of the order of the phoenix now we know
the order of the phoenix as an
organization
comprised of powerful witches and
wizards an organization
with one objective in mind opposed lord
voldemort and the death eaters
the organization was first founded by
dumbledore during the first
wizarding war in the year 1970 created
in response to voldemort returning to
england
and beginning his persecution of
muggleborns the order worked directly
with the ministry of magic
for 11 years in an effort to defeat
voldemort and his
forces spanning from 1970 to 1981
however it of course wasn't until 1981
that voldemort was eventually defeated
at the hands of the potters
the original order then disbanded after
the war ended as there was no longer any
imminent threat
however when voldemort returned in 1995
a second wave of the order reconvened
picking up where they left off
many powerful witches and wizards were
members of the order over the years and
though there were certainly some
casualties during the first wizarding
war
the order was able to obtain some new
members when it was refounded
the collection of witches and wizards
that helped to oppose voldemort was
truly a spectacle
a diverse array of witches and wizards
with their own unique specialties and
talents
in this video i'm going to be discussing
my top 6 order of the phoenix members
this list will include order members
from both the first and second wizarding
wars
without further ado let's get started
number six
kingsley shacklebolt kingsley
shacklebolt was a british pureblood
wizard
order of the phoenix member powerful
aura and later minister for magic
kingsley was a late addition to the
order and joined during the second
wizarding war
shacklebolt attended hogwarts and
performed particularly well on his nudes
fulfilling all the necessary
qualifications to become an aura
before eventually becoming minister for
magic kingsley was a high-ranking aura
and displayed a very powerful and
balanced arsenal of magical capabilities
jacquel's fellow order members held him
in a very high regard
and even lord voldemort himself
considered kingsley to be a powerful
wizard
if that isn't an indicator of his level
of power then i don't know what
is shacklebolt exhibited natural cunning
outstanding dueling ability
full events against the dark arts
proficiency charms mastery
transfiguration mastery potions mastery
herbology mastery
apparitions mastery and more he was
truly a master of
all and was able to comfortably hold his
own against at least two death eaters at
once
in fact during the battle of the seven
potters shacklebolt was chased by five
death eaters
and even though he was primarily focused
on protecting hermione
shacklebolt was able to stun two of them
and escape shakapult was a truly
indispensable addition
to the order number 5. alistair moody
considered by many to be the most famous
aura of all time alistair moody was a
very impressive wizard
moody joined the order during the first
wizarding war and is said to be
personally responsible for a very large
portion of the witches and wizards
in azkaban this earned him quite the
reputation amongst the dark wizard
community
madai was a scottish pure blood wizard
born into the moody family
a family known for producing a plethora
of amazingly talented auras
in his youth he attended hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry
and later on in his life and career true
to his family name
went on to follow in the footsteps of
his family and become an aura
moody was a truly impressive dog wizard
catcher and warrior
he would do whatever it took to win and
moody served with great distinction
during the first wizarding war
even losing an eye leg and nose in
battles against the death eaters moody
was incredibly brave
but also extremely powerful particularly
in his prime
however many do feel as though his
abilities may have peaked during the
first twisting war
and that he had dropped down a peg by
the time the second wizarding war
came around the result of years of hard
battling
similar to shacklebolt moody was
regarded as one of the most powerful
members of the order of the phoenix by
lord voldemort himself
for this reason voldemort suspected that
moody was likely the wizard protecting
harry during the battle of the seven
potters
and was initially targeted by voldemort
for this reason he was a master of dark
arts
defense against the dark arts dueling
charms transfiguration
potions hivology apparition non-verbal
magic
and even occlumency for all of the
reasons listed above i feel that he is
deserving of the number five spots
on this list number four minerva
mcgonagall minerva mcgonagall didn't
join the order until the second
wizarding war
as she instead chose to work as a spy
for the ministry of magic
for the duration of the first war
mcgonagall is a scottish half-blood
witch
that attended hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry and later worked
there
while she attended hogwarts she was the
most talented student of her entire year
and she achieved top grades in her newts
and owls
she exhibited extreme magical prowess
from a very young age
and later became one of hogwarts best
professors and eventually had mistress
mcgonagall's most notable skill is
perhaps related to her knowledge and
talent in transfiguration
she is known for her effortless ability
to transform her physical form
at will she was also a skilled potion
maker able to successfully brew an
animagus potion
and duelist notably dueling lord
voldemort to a standstill
alongside slughorn and kingsley but what
makes mcgonagall particularly powerful
is her paired knowledge of the dark arts
not only did she master charms
transfiguration dueling and potion
making she also had a vast knowledge of
the dark arts
though she didn't use dark spells
frequently she could use them when
necessary and notably used the imperious
curse on amicus cara
number three aberforth dumbledore
aberforth dumbledore was a british
half-blood wizard
the son of kendra and percival
dumbledore older brother to ariana
dumbledore
and perhaps most notably the younger
brother of albus dumbledore
aberforth was known to have a poor
relationship with his brother albus
the result of a three-way jewel
involving aberforth albus and gellert
grindelwald
the jewel resulted in the death of their
sister ariana
and it effectively put an end to their
relationship aberforth later became the
barman at the hogshead inn in hogsmeade
village
and though he had a poor relationship
with his brother joined the order of the
phoenix during the first wizarding war
in an effort to bring peace back to the
wizarding world they had a bad
relationship but aberforth wasn't going
to let that get in the way of stopping
voldemort
though aberforth wasn't quite as
powerful as albus he was still a
dumbledore
and provided that he was able to hold
his own in a three-way jewel involving
grindelwald that i'm sure that he was an
extremely powerful wizard
aberforth preferred to settle his
disputes with jewels and this
is one of the reasons that he became
such a skilled duelist
aberforth was also a charms master and
skilled legitimate
number 2 severus snape now we know
severus snape as lily's suitor the
potions professor
the defense against the dark arts
professor and later headmaster of
hogwarts
despite snape ultimately showing that he
was one of the good guys
he did have a history with the death
eaters and was crooked for a time
snape after all was the one responsible
for telling voldemort about the prophecy
that professor trelawny had predicted
snape is widely considered to be one of
the most gifted wizards in the entire
harry potter series
his skills are only really outmatched by
voldemort and dumbledore
who are in a bit of a class of their own
but snape is extremely powerful
nonetheless during his time at hogwarts
snape assumed the identity
the half bud prince and scribbled all
sorts of spell creations into his copy
of advanced potion making
among these spells was the powerful and
vicious sectim's emperor
snape can also fly and is one of only
two known wizards who are capable of
doing this
the other being voldemort when snape
jules mcgonagall in the film
who is extremely powerful in her own
right he's able to match her despite
holding back
immensely there's no telling what snape
would have been able to accomplish
if he had lived a more linear life snape
died at the tender age of 38
and though he wasn't quite at the level
of voldemort or dumbledore he was
getting there
and had he been around for a few decades
longer i think that snape may have just
had a shot at being the most powerful
wizard ever
number one albus dumbledore now i'm sure
you saw this coming
dumbledore is undoubtedly the most
powerful wizard to have ever lived
comparable only to maybe voldemort or
possibly grindelwald
while at school dumbledore's magical
abilities consistently turned heads
particularly his skills surrounding
charms and transfiguration he also did
exceptionally well on his newts
and griselda marchbanks a professor
working for the wizarding examinations
authority
remarked that albus was able to do
things with a wand that she had never
seen before
dumbledore had no weaknesses he was a
charms and transfiguration master
a skilled oklahomans and versed
practitioner of elemental magic
had dumbledore gone down the same path
as voldemort pursuing an even deeper
level of dark magic
there's no telling how powerful he could
have truly been dumbledore pushed the
limits of magic while staying away from
an entire side of a magical spectrum
and was able to still overpower
voldemort who did whatever it took to
achieve power
and that's it for my top six honourable
mentions include sirius black
remus lupin tonks the longbottoms the
potters
the pruitts and many more there were
many powerful and talented order members
and this list was difficult to make
but i feel pretty good about it what do
you guys think who would you replace
who would you put in your top six let me
know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizardy